[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait à la sphère orpea la ministre
déléguée chargée de l'autonomie des
personnes âgées brigitte bourguignon a
convoqué les deux principaux dirigeants
du groupe leader mondial des ehpad le
gouvernement a lancé deux enquêtes l'une
administrative l'autre financière orpea
est accusé de graves dysfonctionnements
dans le livre les fossoyeurs le
journaliste victor castanet y dénonce
des rationnements une gestion
exclusivement comptable de la prise en
charge des êtres humains vulnérables
orpea réfute ces accusations et va
engager une procédure de plainte en
diffamation
ce livre sort quelques mois avant les
présidentielles et alerte bien sûr les
politiques sur le sujet de la réforme du
grand âge alors quelles sont les dérives
dénoncées par l' enquête de victor
castanet comment s'effectuent les
contrôles des ehpad en france y at il
une maltraitance systémique dans
certains établissements comment
finalement la société prend elle en
charge les personnes âgées
on va en discuter avec mes invités j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés et lise
richard bonsoir à vous journaliste
indépendante auteurs de ces sons de
maltraiter nos vieux et c'est aux
éditions du rocher bienvenue
avec nous également benjamin coriat
bonsoir économiste membre des
économistes atterrés contributeurs à
l'ouvragé soigner manifeste pour une
reconquête de l'hôpital public et du
soin et c'est aux éditions et c et f
bienvenue également benjamin coriat par
skype de lille nous avons avec nous
jérôme malfaisants bonsoir conseiller
syndical du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers mon sort avoue
bienvenue vous avez travaillé 15 ans
dans des ehpad chez korian également la
fondation caisse d'épargné pour la
solidarité
et aujourd'hui vous êtes infirmier
libéral nous avons également avec nous
par sky pascal champvert bonsoir
président de l'association des
directeurs au service des personnes
âgées bienvenue à vous
au sol avant de démarrer cette
discussion je vous propose d'écouter et
de faire un point en images avec nos
confrères de france télévisions
on fait des enquêtes qualité très très
régulièrement dans ses enquêtes qualité
notre taux de satisfaction est de plus
de 90% mais
hier 10 % qui restent mais on peut pas
être à 100% dans ce métier surtout que
des résidants qui arrivent dans nos
établissements sont souvent dans des
états de santé difficile alors ça
c'était la réaction du patron d'orpea
que vous venez d'entendre le tout
nouveau patron qui vient d'être nommé
qu'il se défend en disant que
effectivement il y avait des études qui
avait été fait des études qualitatives
et lise richard vous avez fait vous une
enquête qui se rapproche un petit peu de
celle justement dont on parle vous êtes
allés à la rencontre de personnes âgées
se livrent des fossoyeurs quand vous
l'avez lu ils dénoncent de graves
dysfonctionnements de la clinique de
neuilly en particulier d'orpea l'une des
plus hauts de gamme de france est ce que
vous êtes retrouvé est-ce que vous avez
été témoin de dérive équivalente et
recueilli des témoignages un peu
similaire oui en effet c'est vrai que
tout ce qui est la question donc qui est
dénoncé par mon confrère qui est
notamment la question du rationnement en
fait aussi bien en protection quand en
terme de nourriture c'est des choses que
j'ai moi même dénoncé dans mon livre et
qui était déjà dénoncé auparavant depuis
plusieurs années en fait il ya eu
plusieurs reportages en fait donc
rationnement des couches rapidement des
coups c'est exactement ça veut dire
qu'il ya un quota par résident par jour
du nombre de couches et il ya aussi des
prix qui sont fixés pour le repas donc
ça va de 3,62 à 4,50 en fonction voilà
des groupes et ça veut dire que c'est 3
3 ou 4 euros par jour par résident pour
l'ensemble de repas du petit déjeuner
jusqu'au repas du soir et des éventuels
collation mais ça vous l'avez vu dans
des ehpad publics ou privés ou seulement
privé alors c'est le cas dans les ehpad
privée s'est il ya aussi des budgets
évidemment dans les ehpad publics mais
ce qui est absolument scandaleux c'est
quand on voit le prix payé dans les
ehpad privé lucratif qui peuvent donc
atteindre
on l'a vu cinq six sept mille euros et
de voir que le prix des repas est aussi
faible alors que les résidents paye une
somme astronomique alors justement on va
revenir sur le débat on a maintenant
deux sujets on va le regarder à nos
confrères de france télévisions
sous la pression du gouvernement le
nouveau pdg d'orpea arrive ce matin
convoqué au ministère de la santé pour
donner ses explications
après une heure de rendez vous philippe
charrier nommé il ya tout juste deux
jours à la tête du groupe promet la
transparence sur les accusations de
maltraitances et contre attaque
plusieurs accusations sont infondées
j'en ai la preuve ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que ce que nous avons lu ne
correspond absolument pas à la réalité
de la vie dans nos établissements
pourtant ce matin dans une page a chuté
au journal le parisien philippe charrier
reconnaît dans une lettre à demi mot des
erreurs nous le savons nous le vivons
des manquements peuvent exister malgré
tous nos efforts
la pression s'accentue sur orpea viser
désormais par deux enquêtes ordonnées
par le gouvernement nous lançons je vous
le dis une enquête et gasquet est un
organisme indépendant et une enquête
aussi financière de l'est gf donc c'est
une première parce que il faut taper
fort pour bien montrer qu'on ne fait pas
n'importe quoi dans ce pays dans une
activité qui est lucrative mais qui ne
doit pas être lucrative au détriment de
la bientraitance et de nouvelles
plaintes vont être déposées evelyse
berrebi et son frère accusant pea d'être
responsable de la mort de leur mère là
c'est ma mère avec des bleus est morte à
cause des personnes qui ne sont pas
occupés d'elle parce que ma mère est
tombée à plusieurs reprises
de son lit et de son fauteuil et des
personnes n'ont pas vu la levée de le
rester toute la nuit portefeuille ou sur
le sol une action collective lancée par
des familles se préparent contre orpea
géant malfaisants vous êtes infirmier
vous avez travaillé pour de nombreux
ehpad est ce que ça vous parle ce qu'on
vient de voir et lorsque vous avez lu
également ce livre est ce que vous avez
été confronté à ce type de situation
oui alors
c'est tout de même assez interpellant
parce que au final ces problématiques
las on revient assez régulièrement
effectivement on a une maltraitance
il faut poser le mans est institutionnel
mais on a une maltraitance tout d'abord
qui est celle du personnel à mon sens en
fait la bientraitance des résidents
passent par la bientraitance du
personnel qui sont dans ces
établissements et est aujourd'hui quand
on regarde un petit peu l'historique de
ces différents établissements on
retrouve ce type d'événement de
nom n'est pas nouveau même si en fait ce
livre vraiment jette un pavé dans la
mare non non ce n'est pas nouveau c'est
une situation qui dure moi j'ai commencé
ma carrière en 2014
et déjà on avait ce type d'événement là
et on parlait de ce type d'événement là
on a eu un plan grand âge en 2008 2012
excusez moi du peu mais c'est celle
éléphants qui a accouché d'une souris on
parlait de ratio de 1 pour 1 aujourd'hui
donc un manque de personnel pour un
résident on reste toujours dans les
ratios qui étaient ceux que j'ai connus
c'est à dire 0 6 pour un résident ce
sont des situations qui perdure
maintenant effectivement le diagnostic
est posé à chaque fois les questions c
est qu est ce que l'on en fait quelles
sont les actions ils ont mis au regard
de ça et on voit que di ferro des cours
des différents gouvernements
en fait on a on n'a aucune solution qui
est proposé malgré les les différents
signes en alerte selon que l'on peut
tirer pascal champvert comment expliquer
justement qu'il ya de nombreux signaux d
alerte et que finalement rien ne soit
fait derrière est ce qu'il ya une
spécificité plus forte auprès des ehpad
du privé puisque orpea bien sûr c'est le
leader des ehpad du privé
si vous voulez y à il ya deux jours par
ce qui s'est passé à orpéa si les faits
sont avérés ils veulent avoir des
enquêtes et il va y avoir un travail de
la justice donc nous le verrons à ce
moment là si les faits sont avérés c'est
extrêmement grave mais ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que ce genre de
comportement n'est possible que dans le
secteur de l'aide aux personnes âgées
pourquoi parce que comme vient de le
dire monsieur malfaisants ça fait des
années et des années que l'état ne fait
pas ce qu'il faut en fait la sphère
orpea révèle un scandale d'état et le
scandale d'état c'est quoi est ce qu a
décrit et lise richard dans son
excellent livre c'est que dans les
établissements comme dans les services à
domicile on ne passe pas le temps qu'on
devrait auprès des personnes âgées et ça
dans tous les établissements et dans
tous les services à domicile pourquoi
parce que l'état et les départements
décide du budget de 80 % des
établissements et que dans 80% des
établissements les budgets ne sont pas à
la hauteur pour vous donner juste une
petite comparaison dans les
établissements que je dirige on a des
crèches qui accueille des jeunes enfants
pourquoi ce qui s'est passé à orpéa si
tenté que ce soit exact ne peut pas
arriver dans le secteur de la petite
enfance parce que dans le secteur de la
petite enfance où il existe aussi des
structures privées commerciales privées
associatives ou publics il y à des
ratios de personnel minimum ce que ce à
quoi faisait allusion tout à l'heure le
responsable syndical monsieur
malfaisants et donc quand on n'a pas le
nombre de professionnels imposées par
l'état dans une dose une crèche elle
ferme
quelles sont les réactions justement
parce qu'elles sont les ratios dans
l'exact inverse dans le secteur de
l'aide aux personnes âgées où on nous a
promis qu'en 2012 il y aurait huit
professionnels pour 10 personnes âgées
est l'équivalent dans les services à
domicile et que l'état ne remplit pas
ses engagements
benjamin koré est-ce que c'est
simplement l'état qui est responsable
effectivement parce qu'il ya cette
formation dont on parle entre le nombre
de résidents d'un ehpad et le personnel
le personnel de dead à ses résidents
mais il ya aussi toute la gestion privée
moi j'ai tout de même lui que les ehpad
devenait un produit florissant qui
avaient des rendements très élevés de 4
à 6% est ce que dénonce le livre les
fossoyeurs c'est aussi une reeves
finalement une recherche du profit
maximal au détriment des soins
absolument il ya des responsabilités
croisés mais la première des
responsabilités c'est incontestablement
celle des pouvoirs publics 1 parce que
c'est à eux de prendre en charge la
question du grand âge ça fait très
longtemps qu'on sait qu'il y a la vague
des baby boomers qui arrive maintenant
dans l'âge de la retraite est
pratiquement rien n'a été fait est plus
grave que ça ce qui a été fait c'est que
alors que ce qui était entre les mains
des associations aient été fait à peu
près correctement dans les années
jusqu'aux années 80 on a ouvert la vanne
au privé avec cette idée imbéciles mais
imbéciles vraiment que les retraités
avaient de l'épargnant et que donc il
n'y avait pas besoin de prendre en
charge le secteur et donc on a
marchandises est le grand âge on a
marchandises est la plus grande
faiblesse un de l'être humain donc il ya
une très grande responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics alors ensuite à partir
du moment où on fait rentrer des fonds
activistes 1 dans le capital des ehpad
qu'est ce que vous voulez qui se passe
la première chose qui se passe c'est
qu'on paye d'abord les actionnaires et
on paye les actionnaires par tous les
moyens je suis pas en train de faire de
la littérature la 1re garder la
progression des chiffres d'affaires et
la progression des dividendes versés par
les grands groupes privés et vous allez
voir c'est impressionnant donc ça vient
bien de quelque part et ça vient des
économies fait à la fois sur le
personnel sur la nourriture sur les
conditions de logement sur l'ensemble
des matériaux nécessaires bon j'ai pas
besoin de faire des détails mais donc si
vous voulez il ya une vraie
responsabilité croisés mais le point
central c'est d'avoir mis la vieillesse
dans le marché la vieillesse il faut la
mettre hors marché alors justement de
regarder en chiffres à un petit peu ce
que la france compte en ehpad il ya plus
de sept mille établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes elles accueillent un peu
moins de 600 mille lits et elles se
répartissent entre des structures
publiques 1 45 % des places des maisons
privées à but non lucratif lié à des
associations ou des congrégations des
mutuelles 31% et donc des établissements
privés commerciaux dit lucratif ce dont
vous parliez benjamin quand il ya un
instant c'est 24% ça ce sont les
chiffres sont selon les échos le secteur
privé selon le monde propose en moyenne
des tarifs 40 % plus élevé que le public
avec 10 à 15 % de personnel en moins ce
qui veut bien dire et lise richard que
c'est pas parce que vous mettez
effectivement vos grands-parents dans le
privé qui seront mieux soigner en tout
cas c'était votre constat oui d'ailleurs
il ya un peu une idée reçue on pense
qu'en payant plus cher qu'en mettant
justement son parent sont grands parents
dans une maison de retraite privée à un
prix important on va avoir un meilleur
accompagnement et en fait les chiffres
prouvent exactement le contraire c'est à
dire qu'il ya moins de personnel aussi
bien tous confondus que de personnel
soignant dans les ehpad privé lucratif
que dans les ehpad publics et ça c'est
vrai que ça paraît aberrant parce que on
paye plus cher donc on s'attend à ce
qu'ils aient un meilleur encadrement et
en fait ce n'est pas le cas ce qui veut
bien dire que les établissements privés
lucratifs en tout cas certains et les
plus grands groupes qui font le plus de
bénéfices
rationne en quelque sorte le personnel
en tout cas ne remplace pas autant qu'il
le devrait les congés ou les absences
des salariés justement pour faire du
profit parce qu'ils peuvent gagner de
l'argent justement ne remplacera pas le
personnel bien sûr oui exactement ce que
a priori ils ont a priori le même nombre
de soignants en fait est que dans les
ehpad publics puisque c'est les pouvoirs
publics l'état et les départements qui
financent en fait les postes de
personnels soignants donc à priori ils
ont les mêmes les mêmes taux que dans
que dans le public mais après tout se
joue aussi en effet sur les
remplacements et donc il ya des quotas
qui s'instruit aussi en raison du taux
d'occupation et certains directeurs moi
m'ont confié en fait qu'il avait plus de
marge de manoeuvre c'est à dire que s'il
voulait augmenter le nombre de personnel
ne serait-ce que hôtelier ce qui là est
complètement en fait qui ne dépend pas
de l'état mais simplement de l'ehpad ils
ont ils ont ils sont dans l'incapacité
de le faire parce que justement le siège
leur interdit jérôme malfaisants mais
c'est un problème de modèle économique
où c'est un problème de contrôle parce
que manifestement privé ou public tout
le monde devrait dépendre de la rs et
des conseils départementaux d'après ce
que j'ai lu orpea avait même fait
l'objet d'un contrôle en deux 18
d'ailleurs qui a donné lieu à un rapport
donc il n'y a pas suffisamment de
contrôle
alors je j'ai écouté les différents
propos dans diverses émissions de
monsieur champvert alors effectivement
les contrôles c'est bien mais les
contrôles ça se prépare dans ces
établissements parce qu'au final on est
effectivement prévenu qu'il va y avoir
un contrôle donc tout peut être remis au
carré avant le contrôle et puis est-ce
que c'est véritablement le contrôle qui
est nécessaire ou est ce que c'est
vraiment mettre les moyens au regard des
besoins voilà il faut impérativement que
l'histoire te ment les bloody les
besoins en soins des résidents et et que
l'on mette les moyens en place quand on
parle de ratio il faut faire attention
parce que sont des ratios de personnel
se sont pas des ratios de soignants 1
c'est à dire que un membre le cuisinier
fait partie du personnel dont il fait
partie de ces ratios voilà quand on voit
l'allemagne un petit peu les moyens qui
sont développés en allemagne ou même
dans l'est dans les pays nordiques
on est à 1,2 membres de personnel pour
un résident enfin voila c'est le double
de dust est chez nous en france alors
est ce que c'est un modèle économique
oui effectivement le modèle économique
doit être changée niveau final c'est
juste malheureusement à porter vous ou
apporter plus de financement ces
établissements pascal champvert il ya
tout de même un problème de contrôle où
seulement un problème de modèle
le problème n'est pas d'abord un
problème de contrôle et quand l'état
nous dit on va contrôler bien entendu
que quand il y a des soupçons graves
comme celles qu'un l'arel ce que le
livre n'est soyhières dit qu'il ya assez
fink a pas assez de contrôles en mai
mais le second aspect du problème ce
n'est pas ça le problème c'est pas ça un
problème l'état je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire ce soir que c'est
l'état le premier responsable qu'il y
ait ensuite qu'il y ait des
responsabilités chez européen on verra
on verra ce que les enquêtes en diront
et il est normal compte tenu des
soupçons que l'état fasse des contrôles
spécifiques c'est bien le moins mais
pour l'ensemble des établissements moi
je vous parle des établissements à 2000
ou à 2500 euros par mois là on parle d'
établissements assimilés douze mille
mais pour l'ensemble des établissements
le problème majeur c'est que ces
établissements n'ont pas la maîtrise de
leur budget ce sont les pouvoirs publics
qui décide des budgets et qui décide
donc du nombre de professionnels que
voulez-vous que les preuves les pouvoirs
publics avaient contrôlé dans un
établissement qu'ils ont sous financée
ils vont juste vérifier que
l'établissement ne fait pas tout ce
qu'il devrait parce qu'il est sous
financé donc en fait les pouvoirs
publics ne viennent pas faire ce genre
de contrôle donc oui il faut des
contrôles quand il y a des soupçons de
dysfonctionnements graves mais pour les
dysfonctionnements qu'on le retrouve
dans tous les établissements et aussi je
le répète ne les oublions pas dans les
services à domicile car il faudra
augmenter le nombre de professionnels
dans les établissements mais aussi dans
les services à domicile eh bien il faut
d'abord donner les moyens aux
professionnels de travailler
correctement nous nous proposons dans
l'immédiat un ratio de 8 pour 10 parce
que c'est ce que l'état avait promis il
ya dix ans nous proposons que leur de
services à domicile soit tarifé à 30
euros de l'heure et là quand les
professionnels comme à l'étranger auront
des moyens pour fonctionner alors oui on
pourra faire des contrôles mais à ce
moment là les contrôles devront être
faits par des organismes indépendants du
type parasote par exemple défenseur des
droits qui vérifieront le travail des
professionnels mais aussi le travail des
pouvoirs publics et qui vers feront
aussi si l'état et les départements
tiennent leurs engagements
benjamin coriat am il ya une demande de
justement du privé de la participation
du privé une demande même politique
depuis dix ans puisque j'ai vu
d'ailleurs dans le livre les fossoyeurs
il parle des relations entre le
fondateur du groupe et du ministre à
l'époque xavier bertrand que
effectivement le marché d autorisation d
pad et de cliniques d'ailleurs a explosé
à ce moment là et que d'ailleurs
roselyne bachelot dirait que ça reste
dans la main du ministre un certain
nombre d'autorisations donc les pouvoirs
publics ont besoin du privé parce que
justement il y à une augmentation de la
demande aujourd'hui non on n'est pas du
tout sûr que les pouvoirs publics ont
besoin du privé parce que ils financent
le privé à peu près autant voire
davantage qu'ils financent le public
contenu maintenant de l'importance prise
par le privé est comment dire ce qui
devrait être la valeur ajoutée du privé
se révèlent être
des modes de gestion qui vise d'un des
ancêtres les chambres à tout ce qui
était relié au confort bien évidemment
puisque à priori le personnel il fournit
par l'état que ce soit 2 est pas la
cible et perso publié il ya des gens qui
connaissent mieux le sujet que moi mais
je les avais qu est ce que oui donc si
vous voulez on est dans une situation
dans laquelle on a on a ouvert à la
lucrativité un domaine qui est au moins
aussi également subventionnée que le
secteur public je vais le dire comme je
le pense un c'est ma crainte c'est ma
terreur je vais vous le dire l'ehpad
c'est la préfiguration de l'hôpital de
demain ça veut dire que en ouvrant à la
concurrence
le marché de la vieillesse comme on l'a
fait pour les ehpad de la même manière
qu'on a ouvert à la concurrence
l'hôpital public qui se voit lui dans
une obligation de continuité de service
etc pendant que des établissements
lucratif
tirs vers eux une partie entre entre
guillemets noble et lucrative du soin on
est dans une situation qui est
extrêmement périlleuse donc je ne dis
pas quand je dis il faut mettre hors
marché je ne dis pas que il ne doit pas
y avoir des transactions pour certaines
payantes et c'est jeudi que on doit
d'abord m l'axé 1 et l'accès dans des
conditions dignes et dans des conditions
d'encadrement qu'on répétait les
professionnels du secteur et ensuite
prouvé la machine économique qui paye ça
et ça existe c'est ce qu'ont essayé de
faire dans cet ouvrage soignée qui est
de remettre la dignité au coeur et lise
richard justement est ce qu'il faut est
ce que l'état d'abord a les moyens de
financer le secteur du grand âge alors
quand vous avez fait votre enquête parce
qu'effectivement cette problématique se
pose la question des moyens aprilia la
question aussi de la volonté politique
et c'est vrai que
la question du grand âge c'est une
question qui nous concerne tous on va
tous voilà devenir vieux un jour on a
tous des parents des grands parents âgés
et donc on sait que d'ici 2050 le nombre
de personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie
va doubler donc c'est une question à
laquelle il faut répondre maintenant
moyens ou pas moyen en fait c'est une
priorité demande et qu'il est la
graduation du coup que ça peut
représenter est effectivement enfin vers
la mer des recettes donc ça assure qu'il
faut maintenant il faut financer bien
sûr il ya des choix sociaux 1 milliard
d'euros
nécessaires mais mais encore une fois on
peut pas se passer en fait de cette
question là et on peut pas la balayer
voilà d'un revers de la main et je
rebondis sur ce que dit monsieur
champvert c'est vrai que là on cible sur
ce sur ce livre de monsieur castanet
donc le orpea et le groupe privé
lucratif mais le problème est bien plus
large et une vraie maltraitance
institutionnelle dans tous les
établissements publics associatifs ou
privés lucratifs par manque de personnel
et aussi à domicile en effet par manque
de personnel et est la vraie priorité
pour moi c'est en effet d'augmenter les
ratios de personnel dans tous les
établissements qu'ils soient publics
associatifs ou donc aujourd'hui on est à
combien dans les ratios j'avais vu six à
dix et ça c'est six membres du personnel
pour dix résidents la honda en
équivalent temps plein se dire que c'est
pas y'a pas chaque matin 6 pour 10 ans
tant en fait pour vous donner un exemple
très concret par exemple le matin il va
y avoir trois aides soignants pour une
quarantaine de résidents c'est à dire
que chaque aide soignant va avoir dix
douze toilettes à faire dans une matinée
est énorme une cadence infernale et donc
ils vont se retrouver c'est une moyenne
située noyelles je crois que le calcul a
été fait j'habite chaque résident a
droit à deux heures de présence à soi
d'un soignant soit d'un accompagnateur
est à dire que pendant 22 heures de la
journée il est tout seul donc ça veut
dire qu'une toilette le matin c'est 10
minutes le soir pour toucher 1 résidence
et entre 5 ces cinq minutes mais couché
un résident en fait la prend énormément
de temps parce que il faut bien rappeler
que ce sont des personnes âgées qui sont
fragiles qu'on venant d'être assuré et
on peut pas comme ça à les jeter dans
l'eee en fait il faut prendre le temps
discuter avec elles les accompagner dans
leurs chambres dont six pour disent que
la moyenne c'est largement insuffisant
et largement sur dre effectivement là à
la défenseuse des droits que les raids
on propose 8 pour 10 minimes en a l'air
alerte d'accord sur ce chiffre 8 pour 10
ça serait ça en fait selon votre enquête
qui fonctionnerait mieux mais pour moi
ce serait fin selon les rapports et y en
a eu de multiples qui ont été faits
c'est en effet un minimum mais on peut
aller au delà on peut aller à un pour un
comme le site et monsieur champvert je
pense que après mannheim et sont pas
loin de graisse mettre de limites après
sur le nombre mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que au vu de tous les rapports qui ont
été faits 8 pour 10 est un minimum
jérôme malfaisants donc c'est votre
constat c'est d'abord une question de
ratio entre le nombre de résidents et le
personnel soignant c'est d'abord ça la
clé
il faut
plus globale la prise en charge de la
vieillesse en fait je pense qu'il faut
la solution la plus adaptée au bon
moment au bon
bon patient et avec le bon financement
effectivement on évoquer l'aide à
domicile
c'est à dire qu'il faut voir jusque
quand le la personne âgée peut rester à
son domicile avec l'intégralité des
aides
qui peuvent être mises en place parce
que malgré tout les autres et en
institutionnalisation on change les
repères ce qui n'est pas toujours simple
un âge avancé de la ville
la vie pardon mais il faut effectivement
la vie voir quelle est la bonne solution
au bon moment et il voit requérir
effectivement la proportion qu'il faut
amener vers le maintien à domicile est
ce qu'on ne va pas augmenter le maintien
à domicile parce que les solutions et
ses petits mots vont en augmentant pour
ce matin à domicile est-ce que l'on
traîne institutionnalisation on voit
qu'elle est qu'elle est qu'elle a été
retardé pour des années puisque on
rentrait chement en 2011 je rentre à 84
ans aujourd'hui on rentre à 85 ans donc
pouvoir avoir une vision plus globale la
prise en charge de la personne âgée la
prise en soin de la personne âgée et
effectivement c'est une véritable
réflexion globale qui est à mener alors
c'est une ré véritable réflexion pascal
champvert j'imagine que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça une réflexion dont on
parle peu finalement dans la campagne
présidentielle même si effectivement ce
livre a jeté un pavé dans la mare et qui
commençait à avoir des propositions de
différents candidats c'est une réflexion
globale il faudrait pouvoir le but
j'étais le financer ça représente
combien si effectivement décide du jour
au lendemain de ne plus utiliser le
priver du tout que tout soit par exemple
un service public c'est ce que propose
par exemple les a soumis un grand
service public ou même encore fabien
roussel qui est lui favorable aussi un
grand secteur public du grand âge qu'est
ce que ça pourrait représenter
financièrement je l'ignorent et je ne
suis pas capable de répondre à cette
question j'entends bien que ça fait
partie du débat public mais indemniser
les propriétaires en cas de
nationalisation coûterait encore plus
cher et malheureusement je ne crois pas
dans un premier temps que ce soit là
qu'il faille mettre les moyens je pense
que les moyens il faut les mettre dans
tous les établissements publics
associatifs et les établissements
commerciaux qui fonctionne correctement
car il y en a pour augmenter je ne parle
pas de ceux qui sont cotées en bourse ce
sont des des cas particuliers mais les
établissements commerciaux qui
fonctionnent normalement les
établissements publics et associatifs
doivent voir leur nombre de
professionnels augmenter comme ça vient
d'être dit après je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec le fait qu'il faut une
vision globale
premiers éléments il faut considérer
dans notre société que les personnes
âgées sont des citoyens à part entière y
compris si elles sont vulnérables si
elles sont fragilisées sûr est que ce ne
sont pas des sous-hommes ou death ou
femme mais que ce sont des citoyens à
part entière qui doivent être
accompagnés qui doivent être entendus y
compris si elles ont des difficultés
physiques ou psychiques et c'est
possible de le faire quand on a le temps
précisément de le faire et puis les
écouter cela veut dire quoi eh bien
quand on écoute les personnes âgées
comme nous le faisons à l'un des pas
dans le cadre d'une démarche qui
s'appelle citoyenne âge qui donne la
parole aux personnes très âgées eh bien
on se rend compte que ce qu'elle demande
en premier c'est de la liberté c'est de
l'autonomie et pour faire cela
évidemment ce qu'il faut c'est revoir le
fonctionnement des services à domicile
beaucoup plus s'appuyer sur la personne
sur la parole des personnes âgées et une
fois qu'on aura donné les moyens
supplémentaires nécessaires dans les
établissements les services à domicile
transformer les établissements en
domicile regrouper monsieur malfaisants
tout à l'heure par
d'institutionnalisation c'est ça qui est
dramatique les établissements dans
l'avenir ne doivent plus être des
institutions mais peuvent être des
domiciles regroupé avec des citoyens que
l'on accompagne dignement benjamin
coriat sacré proposition la grippe a
mais c'est toute la famille se sent bien
parce que là pour le coup ça demande à
un immense projet ça demande un débat
politique on n'a pas véritablement on va
juste pour pour illustrer un petit peu
on va écouter par exemple valérie
pécresse qui a fait quelques
propositions et on va voir que justement
on en est pas à ce grand débat sociétés
dont vous parlez oui
on va remettre de l'ordre on va mettre
des indicateurs de qualité de soins pour
les résidents des ehpad et ses
indicateurs de qualité de soins ils
seront publiques pour les ehpad privé
comme pour les ehpad publics qu'on les
rendra publics et on va les contrôler et
tous ceux qui sont qui manque à leur
mission de service public tous ces
patrons qui mettent leurs profits avant
la dignité humaine de leurs résidents eh
bien nous les poursuivrons s'était
concentré quand elle parle de contrôle
elle est très gentil c'est des propos de
campagne c'est normal parce que je veux
dire mettre des indicateurs de contrôle
de qualité de soins très bien est-ce
qu'on commence par des indicateurs de
dotation de moyens permettant une
qualité de soins est-ce qu'on commence
par ça un bon donc je veux dire c'est
normal je veux dire elle fait elle fait
son métier lui position pardon
l'insoumise caroline fiat qui elle dit
interdiction des ehpad privé recrutement
de plus de 200 mille personnes un ratio
d'encadrement alors 0 6 ans et moins oui
oui elle a fait une estimation alors je
te parle à l'économie ce que vous êtes
benjamin coriat elle dit que c'est huit
milliards d'euros soit 2 isf ça paraît
peu 8 milliards d'euros oui ça paraît
peu mais surtout moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que
la solution n'est certainement ni la
privatisation du grand âge et le
transformer en marché ni l'étatisation
complète on a affaire à des hommes on a
offert à des humains on a affaire à des
situations qui sont extrêmement
différentes et je pense qu'il faut aller
vers un modèle différencier ça veut dire
que on aura sans doute besoin
d'établissements spécialisés de type
ehpad à condition qu'ils soient équipés
de la manière qui convient et qui à ce
moment là ils soient contrôlés on aura
besoin de développer
le soin à domicile etc mais on aura
besoin aussi très probablement de
coopératives de quartier
d'agencement d'immeubles 1 je veux dire
il faut il faut réfléchir à ça à la
hauteur de la question qui est posée
bon dans toutes les familles dont tous
les immeubles il y a des gens qui sont
en souffrance et qu'on envoie quand on
peut dans des ehpad les moins pires
possible et souvent ils sont plisson n'a
même pas extraordinaire bien quelque
chose à penser on peut très bien écouter
on a fait des contraintes dans des
contraintes d'urbanisme sur les garages
on pourrait pas faire des contraintes du
rga ni d'urbanisme pour la contrainte
pour le logement des vieux du quartier
ou de l'immeuble etc on peut penser il
faut penser fermant une formule
complètement différent et d'un point de
vue budgétaire qu'est ce que c'est c'est
à ce moment là que le budget se
présentera de manière tout à fait
différente si vous voulez faire des
bulles
ultrasophistiqués cetera à la place des
ehpad ça va coûter extrêmement cher si
vous êtes capable de
conforter prolongée et le travail
domestique et le travail
sanitaire fait par le service public
avec un hôpital qui va vers un qui n'est
pas enfermé dans sa forteresse mais qui
a des équipes mobiles etc dont il faut
repenser c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
faire dans ce livre on sait très bien
que c'est pas pour demain matin mais si
on peut donner dix ans il faudra un plan
à dix ans il faut il fautif c'est comme
toujours il faut l'urgence et l'urgence
et du personnel pour les ehpad et cetera
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus bien et
ensuite il faut un modèle de moyen terme
et de long terme et il faut s'y engager
sans tarder ça fait 30 ans qu'on aurait
dû le faire bon je n'y serais jamais
trop tard vous vous aviez des
propositions dans votre livre également
et c'est vrai en fait ce qui est
dramatique dans cette histoire c'est que
là le scandale éclate donc les pouvoirs
publics réagissent mais en fait faut
quand même rappeler qu avait une loi en
préparation la loi grand âge et
autonomie qui avaient été promises par
le président et qui a été en fait
enterrer qui ne verra pas le jour avant
la fin du quinquennat ça c'est certain
et 7 pour avoir votre avis après les
raisons elles sont multiples et des
raisons financières mais il a aussi des
raisons encore une fois de volonté
politique derguy raison d'un agenda etc
mais là la question c'est qu'en fait ça
fait des années
que les problématiques en ehpad à donner
si elles sont connues que les
difficultés sont connus que les
professionnels les dénonce et que rien
n'est fait donc encore une fois ce qu'il
faut en effet c'est pouvoir
faire une loi une loi de grande
envergure pour réformer l'ensemble du
secteur de l'accompagnement des
personnes âgées et pas uniquement se
focaliser sur les ehpad et encore moins
sur les ehpad uniquement privé lucratif
la question allait
là-bas lausanne et aux instituts ne
voient une oie d'envergure qui puisse
répondre et qu'ils puissent donner aussi
une unité parce qu'il faut pas tout
cloisonnement ce qu'enfin mois dans les
dents les les solutions que j'aime et
que j'ai émises dans le livre il ya
aussi beaucoup de passerelles en fait
entre les ehpad entre le domicile il ya
maintenant des expérimentations des
paddocks hors les murs qui existent bien
sûr où ça est ce qu'un exemple justement
dont on pourrait s'inspirer ça existe
dans il ya des expérimentations un peu
partout en france il ya après aussi des
systèmes des alternatives des systèmes
de familles d'accueil des systèmes de
d'habitat partagé etc il ya derrière des
ltte au père active d'anciens qui se
sont auto organisés qui ont demandé un
soutien public il faut vraiment penser
de manière ouverte mais excusez moi je
vous ai un terrain je vous en prie alesi
et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui existent il ya énormément de
d'initiatives très positive qui sont
faites par les acteurs du secteur et
qu'il faut auxquels il faut donner les
moyens en fait aussi de développer
justement ce type d'initiative est
encore une fois je pense que ça passe
nécessairement par une loi
pour pouvoir financer tout ça jérôme
faisant il faudrait une grande loi
effectivement de prise en charge du
troisième âge des personnes âgées
oui c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure au final à chaque fois les
problèmes se sont posés les problèmes
sont identifiés
alors on répond un petit peu à l'image
de ce que faisait madame pécresse dans
l'urgence à la problématique est posée à
l'instant t mais effectivement on a une
vision un petit peu tu alors que je
pense que ce soit on s'accorde à avoir
une vision beaucoup plus large
regardez le cas donné le plan grand âge
2008 2012 effectivement cette cette loi
grand âge elle comme ricky qui a été un
qui a été avorté
oui effectivement mais il faut une
réflexion portée de solution suffisante
à vous écouter cette loi
soit appliquée
même pas venu et
les solutions se souhaiter et il faut
une réflexion était beaucoup plus large
et oui ce n'est pas une réflexion court
termiste qui est une réflexion sur bien
évidemment sur l'habitat sur le
personnel sur la formation du personnel
sur sur des moyens qui sont novateurs il
faut avoir une vision un petit peu
nouvelle sûr c'est une véritable
réflexion de société oui quelle est la
place qu'on donne la nausée dès
aujourd'hui dans la société française
d'aujourd'hui malheureusement les ailes
et elle est peu importante je passais a
changé elle est peu importante cette
place alors que lorsqu'on regarde les
statistiques c'est ça ne fait
qu'augmenter forcément c'est un problème
démographique car avant tout 2030 la
france comptera 21 millions de seniors
de plus de 60 ans dont 3 millions de
plus qu'en 2019 il y aura plus de cent
mille nouvelles demandes d pas d'un
selon les statistiques dans les dix
prochaines années c'est donc plus du
double du rythme annuel de création et
donc effectivement on l'attend ce grand
débat on attend une grande loi c'est ça
aussi votre conclusion bien sûr il est
clair que les politiques aujourd'hui
comprennent mieux les enjeux écologique
à 10 15 ans et encore ce n'est pas
toujours le cas que les enjeux
démographiques à 5 10 ans mes joueurs
dire deux choses 1 il faut une grande
loi nous sommes tous d'accord on nous
demande combien coûte cette grande loi
on peut ajouter des milliards et des
milliards pour faire peur à tout le
monde et être certain que la grande loi
ne se fera pas mais il faut bien avoir
en tête que la première importance et
augmenter le nombre de professionnels à
domicile en établissement s'est créé
trois cent mille emplois 300 villes en
place c'est diminuer le chômage d'autant
m'a jamais coria expliquerez ça
certainement mieux que moi mais diminuer
le chômage de 300000 personnes ça ça
n'est pas rien dans une société comme la
nôtre moi je préfère avoir trois cent
mille personnes qui travaillent auprès
des personnes âgées que d'avoir trois
cent mille chômeurs mais le deuxième
élément sur lequel je voudrais insister
c'est que il faut agir là maintenant
tout de suite et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous demandons au président
macro de prendre la parole sur ce sujet
je le disais tout à l'heure on est face
à un scandale d'état le président de la
république doit s'exprimer très
rapidement et avant la fin de son
quinquennat il doit mettre en oeuvre des
mesures concrètes une grande loi il n'en
a plus le temps mais des mesures
concrètes simple nous par exemple nous
proposons la création de deux postes
supplémentaires dans chaque
établissement dans chaque service à
domicile et cela cela montrera
concrètement qu il y a une volonté
politique de faire et cela permettra ça
ne réglera pas tous les problèmes mais
ça permettra déjà d'avoir des personnes
âgées qui sont mieux accompagner et des
conditions de travail pour les salariés
qui seront moins dégradée benjamin koré
nous reste deux minutes un ange à
j'approuve entièrement cette idée on va
répéter ce qu'on a dit parce que je
pense qu on a dit des choses sensées
aussi vous pensez que manuel macron
devrait vraiment savez les maladies
d'ailleurs que l'on devait de la classe
m
demandez un magnol m'apprend
d'intervenir pourquoi pas mais il faut
que l'ensemble des candidats se
manifestent et fasse de la santé
publique dont la vieillesse qui se
présentent aujourd'hui se forme de
scandale une priorité je veux dire on
sort d'une pandémie enfin on espère
qu'on sort d'une pandémie et on a un
hôpital qui va crouler on laisse faire
on laisse faire bon donc je veux dire la
question de la santé publique
y compris celle des ehpad qui se
rappellent si je peux dire est
clairement une des priorités et il faut
pas seulement que le président bacon se
prononcent mais que les candidats en
face un vrai sujet des loups proposition
viserait à moi parce que les os que les
citoyens ont à se prononcer là dessus
les enchères un mot de conclusion oui
c'est vrai qu'il ya une loi à voter qui
peut prendre du temps mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya aussi des priorités des
urgences et c'est vrai que comme le
disait monsieur champvert la priorité
elle est d'augmenter le personnel et un
domicile et en ehpad pour pouvoir en
fait régler le problème d'urgence et la
maltraitance des personnes âgées et
aussi des personnels merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous et lise richard
merci benjamin coriat merci à vous
pascal champvert d'avoir été avec no
mercy avoue jérôme malfaisants merci à
vous tous et toutes nous avoir suivis
reste avec nous sur france 24